we just celebrated your dad's birthday a
couple days ago so what does it mean to
you to be here tonight you know in just
a couple days after his birthday I'm
just so proud of it all
um
it's all flowing really nicely together
that was Lisa Marie Presley opening up
to ET on Tuesday night just two days
before her sudden death now Lisa Marie's
ex-husband Michael Lockwood is speaking
out in a statement to E.T Michael's
attorney says the guitarist is focusing
on their 14 year old twin daughters
Harper and Finley adding that Michael
had been hoping for a speedy and
complete recovery and is very sad it
didn't turn out that way quote Michael's
world has been turned on its ear he's so
even killed and he's really calm and he
talks you know people he cares he takes
care of everything I've just never seen
anyone like him Lisa Marie the daughter
of Elvis and Priscilla Presley married
Michael in 2006. the two welcomed their
twin girls two years later I don't know
what to do with myself I'm not if I'm
not a mom in 2016 Lisa Marie filed for
divorce after 10 years of marriage the
two had a very content highly publicized
custody battle which ended in 2020 with
a joint custody agreement
Lisa Marie died on Thursday after going
into full Cardiac Arrest at her home in
Calabasas responders performed CPR
before transporting her to the hospital
where she was placed in a medically
induced coma and eventually on life
support before she was pronounced dead
Thursday evening she was 54 years old
following news of her death stars have
shared their condolences on social media
longtime friend John Travolta wrote Lisa
baby girl I'm so sorry I'll miss you but
I know I'll See You Again Leah Remini
tweeted that she is heartbroken Octavia
Spencer echoed that writing that she is
so sad that we've lost another bright
star meanwhile Tom Hanks who starred in
Elvis the recent biopic about her father
alongside Austin Butler said he is
absolutely broken
who is too much rain so what was it like
watching Austin on stage and during this
movie it was mind-blowing truly
mind-blowing I really didn't know what
what to do with myself after after I saw
it yeah I I had to take like five days
to process it
because it was so incredible and so spot
on
and so authentic Lisa Marie attended the
Golden Globes Tuesday with her mom
Priscilla by her side I'm here to
support Austin and baz and film and I'm
so excited and I hope he wins well
Austin did win and thanked the Presley
family on stage
thank you for opening your hearts your
your memories your home to me Lisa Marie
Priscilla I love you forever following
her death a rep for the Presley family
released a statement to E.T that they
are shocked and devastated quote they
are profoundly grateful for the support
love and prayers of everyone and ask for
privacy during this very difficult time
[Music]
thank you